what happened II didn't have it in it
good did it I did it
yes yes yes
I suppose inspiration is what comes
before motivation seeing a good idea and
gave me that feeling this could return
to something really really good there
are still things that have not been done
before I think my experience proves is
even something really a bit mad if you
can do it really well if no one else is
doing it all you can lose is your time
the world is full of paddlers which are
there to be found
people like paddlers the Kurtz and a
partner nature grows in pattern of
nature versions of Windows rules of
mathematics how to fill a space is most
efficient manner
inspiration is a word which has quite a
little different interpretations to it I
think ask a lot of people inspiration
means you'll get quite a lot of
different answers but I think
inspiration is something that leads to
motivation I want to create something
and create something good here
I said area let me count paces because
where it was want to look good
what's gone wrong
I'm very glad that I've come across
something that hasn't been done before
that other people think is all value now
I thought I do say worthwhile I'm not
just a local lunatic who's making these
strange patterns they'll get covered up
two days later
I hope it's gonna get both your
hopefully good one
there's always a sense of anticipation
because you never really know what it's
going to look like until you see it
I'm really happy with the result we've
got here it's true because it's such
good snow certainly makes it unusual it
might be unique yes it might be unique
you
you